il est bien tout seul ça c'est
impressionnant en fait il est très bien
il est grand et lé talent on est bien
ici il ya deux grands écrans et tout ça
c'est super c'est impeccable c'est
propre c'est immense s'est vraiment
c'était super
le seul dans cette partie mais il est
vachement moderne et ben c'est tout neuf
donc forcément c'est super cool
ce mercredi 26 juin et particulier au
centre commercial parly 2 en plus des
nouveaux films de la semaine un nouveau
cinéma ouvre ses portes c'est l'ugc ciné
cité par lee 12 salles sur trois niveaux
avec une capacité d'accueil de 2200
places
on a un très bon rapport à l'écran
quelle que soit la salle dans lesquels
on sera installé avec une projection
laser dans toutes les salles et du son
7.1 l'a également dans toutes les salles
l'objectif étant de pouvoir offrir aux
spectateurs et aussi au film quel que
soit le film dans la salle les
meilleures conditions de projection la
plus grande salle fait 347 place avec un
écran de 18 mètres de base
le chantier de cette construction a été
lancée en 2010 est l'aménagement du
cinéma depuis novembre 2018
on arrive par un rôle qui est
complètement vitré ce hall d'accueil qui
nous permet d'arriver ensuite sur un
foyer principal qui va desservir toutes
les salles on a deux très beaux espaces
d'attentes
c'est un très bon emplacement c'est un
beau potentiel c'est surtout qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une attente très forte
autour du projet l'ouverture de cette
structure le retour du 7ème art aux
chaînés rocancourt en juin 2014
un cinéma de cinq salles installées sur
le parking du centre commercial avait
fermé ses portes